tiro uma série sempre acaba a refeição
eu perco a fome mais a pose de nanã
português nep chatinho está a cantar
se ninguém com o militar é manco bem sem
curtida fico boba abel
mesmo quando a fonte sem caça época
opção só arroz com feijão tá eu não
tenho muito prova está aí todos neve
ator eu finjo vida ganha mas eu tô na
mão lá só para enganar latiro céu
fazendo biquinho de tudo eu faço o
salvar alguém curtir aberta ilusão
segurando pega uma passando mal
luís neves shetty antónio mega não tem
ninguém pra ver
mas do monstra que o seu gado quanto
tiro no céu
eu sou assim eu sei não é normal
enquanto eu caiu todos nep chan
minha vida é tão sem graça mais escondo
bem só estudará a minha caso quem me
convém parece o mar uma opção na parte
arrumada mas é uma ti ti né tiver lugar
o meu saldo ainda é devedor aluguel
atrasando seu barriga já cuba em gás
terminou já mas eu tenho que deixar
rolar
luis michel como kavian tá pra disfarçar
é só pra ganhar light lussel fazendo
aqui de tudo eu faço só paguem curtir o
dérbi de busão segurando pega na mão
passando mal pois nep chade antônio
legal não tem ninguém pra ver
mas vou mostrar que o sol gagar quanto
tiro certo
eu sou assim eu sei não é normal e do
dew cargo todos né pelo chef preparar
nos separar
na paraíba
'para preparado por 70 6 na taxa para
aceitar entrar pra parar a discussão que
está sendo chato
é galera você que curte essa paródia não
se esquece aplicar aqui embaixo e gostei
volta lá no facebook eu postei clicar em
curtir marca teu amigo os comentários
que ele sabe que é viciado em self que
tira self de tudo e é isso aí moleque
também faz faz depp toda hora esse é o
tirulipa só do ronaldo ele é só clicar
aqui na cara dele você tá pelo
computador quem tá pelo celular clica no
primeiro na descrição do vídeo para se
inscrever no canal do tiro ii papel meu
canal interno a não ser passar minha
também já está no canal vem pro meu
canal estatal e se escreve lá tamo junto
agradeci aí o parceiro meu parceiro da
paródia aí o não famoso daniel não
famoso meu parceiro da paranóia na
verdade inscrição aqui também deu junto
a isso não é nossa é nossa e deles é só
desligar viu o beijo foi no canal
abastado tamo junto nós é e compartilhe
tenha compartilhado